52 53 54 cioè signora se non rispondere
nessuno io vado avanti eh il suo numero
l'ho chiamato un'ora fa Ah questo bel
giovanotto cosa diamo due etti di
bresaola va benissimo caro anch'io in
più che faccio l'asso altro signora
gliela faccio sentire sottile quasi
trasparente Eh come piace a lei signora
più sottile di così si sbriciola eh
signora abbiamo otto tipi di prosciutto
se non vuole grasso ne scelga uno che
abbia meno Grassi non è che posso
mettermi qui a Vivi sezionare il
prosciutto Ma scusi Panzetta magra Mi sa
che non ce l'ho la pancetta magra e mi
manca vicino Come faccio a togliere il
grasso dal salame Ma scusi Dai dopo
signora prosciutto Va bene Chiudo cotta
stagionato piccante Dolce Salato coi
cuoricini ricamato come vuole senta o il
San Daniele che è una nuvola lo vuole
assaggiare perfetto €40 al kg viene
quanto Gliene dà per caso vuole anche
questo che nella affettatrice così mi
evita di no signora È uscito qualcosina
in più che faccio Adesso lascio
no signora mi dispiace ho appena chiuso
Eh ho appena pulito l'affettatrice eh